most atoms don't ride solo instead they
bond with other atoms now bonds can form
between atoms of the same element or
atoms of different elements you've
probably imagined bonding as a
tug-of-war if one atom is really strong
it can pull one or more electrons off
another atom then you end up with one
negatively charged ion and one
positively charged ion and the
attraction between these opposite
charges is called an ionic bond this is
the kind of sharing where you just give
away your toy to someone else and then
never get it back
table salt sodium chloride is held
together by ionic bonds every atom of
sodium gives up one electron to every
atom of chlorine ions are formed and
those ions arrange themselves in a 3d
grid called
a lattice in which every sodium ion is
bonded to six chloride ions and every
chloride ion is bonded to six sodium
ions the chlorine atoms never give the
sodium atoms their electrons back now
these transactions aren't always so cut
and dried if one atom doesn't completely
overwhelm the other they can actually
share each other's electrons this is
like a potluck where you and a friend
each bring a dish and then both of you
share both dishes each atom is attracted
to the shared electrons in between them
and this attraction is called a covalent
bond the proteins and DNA in our bodies
for example are held together largely by
these covalent bonds some atoms can
covalently bond with just one other atom
others with many more the number of
other atoms one atom can bond with
depends on how its electrons are
arranged so how are electrons arranged
every atom of a pure unbonded element is
electrically neutral because it contains
the same number of protons in the
nucleus as it does electrons around the
nucleus and not all of those electrons
are available for bonding only the
outermost electrons the ones in orbitals
furthest from the nucleus the ones with
the most energy only those participate
in bonding by the way this applies to
ionic bonding to remember sodium
chloride well the electron that sodium
loses is the one furthest from its
nucleus and the orbital that electron
occupies when it goes over to chlorine
is also the one furthest from its
nucleus but back to covalent bonding
carbon has four electrons that are free
to bond nitrogen has three oxygen two so
carbon is likely to form four bonds
nitrogen 3 and oxygen to hydrogen only
has one electron so it can only form one
bond in some special cases atoms can
form more bonds than you'd expect but
they better have a really good reason to
do so or things tend to fly apart groups
of atoms that share electrons covalently
with each other are called molecules
they can be small for example every
molecule of oxygen gas is made up of
just two oxygen atoms bonded to each
other or they can be really really big
human chromosome 13 is just two
molecules but each one has over 37
billion atoms and this neighborhood this
city of atoms is held together by the
humble chemical bond